[Music]
marvel's moon knight is here with a pair
of personalities and a very cool suit
the first episode is full of twists and
turns but it's the ending that reveals
the most about moon knight and his foes
warning spoilers ahead
steven grant is a man tormented by a
situation that he doesn't fully
understand and he tries to control his
tendency to wander around while he's
unconscious with a number of diy tricks
it's clear that this has been going on
for a long time and moonlight episode 1
is when everything finally changes as
the first episode nears its end stephen
gets to peek behind the veil when he
discovers physical evidence of another
personality's existence tucked away in a
hidey hole in his apartment a cell phone
he discovers is a particularly important
find because it introduces viewers to
multiple potentially important
characters shortly after discovering the
old phone stephen gets a call on the
other end an unfamiliar woman named
layla has been trying to reach a man
named mark for what appears to be weeks
who do you think i am what do you mean
who what's wrong with you mark
layla might very well turn out to be the
mcu version of mark's romantic interest
in the comics marlene the other name in
the miss calls list duchamp is also very
interesting duchamp is almost certainly
frenchy duchamp mark's old mercenary
friend and ally in the comics it remains
to be seen whether his name is a simple
easter egg or a tease of the character's
on-screen debut still the fact that he
exists in the mcu implies that mark and
frenchie's old mercenary boss and moon
knight arguably greatest enemy rattle
buschmann also lurks somewhere in the
world while mark's formidable nemesis
seems like the kind of character the mcu
might want to save for moonlight season
2 or even a movie fans will no doubt
welcome this low-key confirmation that
bushman might make an appearance at some
point down the line
in the comics moon knight's various
personalities often converse with each
other and konju is fond of making
physical appearances in all of his
bird's girl-headed glory it's a pretty
wild concept for a live-action show and
indeed moon knight episode 1 makes it
clear that the series intends to keep
such interactions at a relatively muted
voices in his head level during the
mid-episode chase scene f murray
abraham's kanchu establishes himself as
a pestering presence that mostly uses
his booming voice to express
exasperation over stephen's lack of
mercenary prowess
the idiot's in control
while the discovery of mark's phone
finally clues stephen into the fact that
he shares his body with another identity
it also spirals his life further into
disarray his existence is suddenly all
about mark talking to him through
mirrors and consume manifesting in front
of him in dramatic horror movie fashion
though these experiences are obviously
no fun for steven the mirror dialogue is
an effective visual technique that
translates the identity's comic book
conversations to the live-action medium
meanwhile khanshu's ominous stalking
hallway appearance is that complete odds
with the almost flipping way the
characters disembodied voice converses
with steven earlier in the episode this
gives the viewer a glimpse of the
character's unpredictable otherworldly
nature as well as the moon god's
tendency to ignore the mental well-being
of its avatar
it becomes clear very quickly that moon
knight's primary nemesis arthur harrow
is more than a small time cult leader
with a penchant for filling his shoes
with ground glass not only does the
villain have the powers of ahmet and
egyptian goddess of justice but the cult
he leads has also infiltrated all levels
of society this is revealed when harrow
confronts stephen and the british museum
so you really do work here oh god i'd
assumed stephen grant was an alias i'll
imagine my surprise to find you here
yet the security guard whom stephen
knows and who's clearly been at the
museum for a while is a full member of
team ahmet this fact is confirmed when
the guard reveals a scale tattoo on his
arm similar to the one harrow possesses
it means that the guard has been at the
museum for reasons that have nothing to
do with stephen which in turn implies
one of two things either harrow place a
guard there for an entirely unrelated
purpose or his call are simply so
formidable that he has followers
everywhere considering the museum's vast
egyptology department with a vast
collection of ahmed themed artifacts the
placement of the guard doesn't seem
accidental and when harrow proceeds to
outright state that his plans for the
world will cause millions of deaths it
becomes clear that he's a global threat
while it remains to be seen just how
widespread the cult of ahmed is this
version of arthur harrow is definitely a
far more powerful and dangerous man than
the mad doctor from the comics as
harrow's summoned jackal creature corner
stephen in the museum bathroom and
starts punching his way through the
heavy doors it's clear that the beast's
strength matches its supernatural
creepiness fortunately a panicked mirror
conversation between stephen and mark
convinces the timid brit to yield
control of their shared body just as the
creature burst through the doors stephen
stephen i could save us
i can't have you fighting me this time
what follows is yet another scene
straight out of a horror movie at least
for the jackal moon knight completely
and utterly overwhelms and destroys the
beast ignoring its feeble attempts to
defend itself and taking it down with a
few brutal attacks this short scene ends
the episode with a punch literally and
while it gives viewers the first good
look at the awesome moonlight costume it
also offers a sample of something even
more interesting the character's powers
moon knight's strength is all over the
place in the comics to put it mildly
sometimes he's just a well-trained guy
with some gadgets and kevlar at the
times he commands a vast array of super
powers that allow him to take down the
avengers all by himself as such it's
interesting to see where on the sliding
scale the mcu character lands based on
the fact that he effortlessly defeats
the superpowered jackal creature it's
clear that he's no weakling there's no
telling what he can do when he unleashes
his weapons and really lets loose but we
have a sneaking suspicion that future
episodes of moon knight will shed plenty
of light on his true power level
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
moon night are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you